thank you everyone for your concern yeah
kylie jenner has seen your tweets about
her shower
and simply can't be bothered thank you
in fact she just proved the joke is
actually
on all of us i'm having so much fun for
those of you who don't have the
slightest clue what i'm talking about
let's refresh earlier this week the
beauty mogul showed off her shower on
instagram yeah that's like a very fancy
very pink
marble shower at her kylie cosmetics
headquarters
a not-so-subtle reminder that she is
very
very rich it's not like that was handed
to her she figured that all out
anyway it didn't take long for people to
chime in on social media
throwing mad shade at well
the water pressure yeah
that actually happened and to be fair
the water pressure does seem a little
light
but like really people and while
everyone was having a grand old time
ripping into what they think is
lackluster water pressure
kylie was too busy living it up on a
dreamy vacation to really know what was
going on
well until now that is okay
good morning everybody it is a beautiful
day
um i keep seeing on the internet
my shower the 23 year old makeup mogul
hit up her insta story to set the record
straight in what might be the most epic
mic
drop of all time if you don't know what
i'm talking about i post a video
of my shower at my headquarters my
offices
which i love okay the subtext here is
awesome
listen up i'm a billionaire boss with a
shower in my office
okay continue i think it's an amazing
shower i have no problem with it but
everyone seems to find my water pressure
very concerning so this is really my
shower at my house
this is my everyday shower oh and her
everyday shower is like
nasa level awesome my everyday shower
okay my only shower isn't even close to
being that chic
or chic at all it's amazing you turn it
on
sorry i don't know why it's a little
blurry turn it on from right here you
could do
set your temperature i like 102.
yeah she doesn't have to stick her hand
in the shower and get it wet to turn on
the water
and she can pick the freaking
temperature
mind freaking blown and right here is
where she shuts down
all that water pressure hate because
yeah apparently that's a thing
this is my water pressure
it's amazing thank you everyone for your
concern thank you everyone for your
concern
now i'm off to go shower in my only
shower
with a manual faucet handle okay